in the comics the Avengers take on a
little bit of everything from alien
hordes to hungry vampires they've based
it all but the buffet of beasts and
villains found on the page meant that
the movies would have to reconcile all
that fantasy with at least some
semblance of reality it's one thing to
have gods
robots and wizards rubbing elbows in a
comic book
but in live-action films striving to be
taken seriously that's a bit more
difficult the solution was a consistent
theme throughout the MCU films the
notion that in the Marvel world magic
and science are the same the characters
we might otherwise perceive as gods or
magical monsters are just aliens a
flying hammer and a rainbow bridge are
no different than one of rocket racoons
cool gadgets
the idea is to ground everything in some
basis of reality with the release of
thor ragnarok though all that change and
with it some fundamental aspects that
the Marvel Cinematic Universe were
scrubbed out the movie was so much fun
no one seemed to notice but here's a
spoiler filled look at how thor ragnarok
may have radically changed the MCU
this not possible
darling you have no idea what's possible
not gods in the comics there's no
argument Thor is a gun so are Odin and a
bunch of other characters and it never
seems to bother anyone that all these
gods of Greek and Norse mythology are
hanging out in New York City having
brawls this hasn't been the case in the
films in 2011's Thor it was implied that
as Guardians were not gods but aliens
mistaken as gods by the Vikings you
could argue that there was some debate
on the issue outside of Thor while Thor
never calls himself a god in early
movies plenty of other characters do
Black Widow
Tony Stark and Nick Fury all call him a
god but they're all members of the same
primitive culture unable to comprehend
the Asgardians
so you have to take their assessment
with a grain of salt meanwhile even
though Loki refers to himself as a God
considering his arrogance he'd likely
call himself that whether he was from
Asgard or Hoboken by the first few
minutes of 2013's the dark world the
matter seems settled as Odin says we are
not gods we're born we live we die just
as humans do so if the earlier films let
the matter of their heritage unanswered
the dark world told us once and for all
or at least for a little science and
magic at the same time the MC use
filmmakers seem to want to prepare
audiences for the synergy between
science and magic they would see in
Avengers by laying the groundwork in
Thor and Captain America at the First
Avenger in Thor the Odin son tells Jane
Foster your ancestors called it
and you call it science well I come from
a place where that one in the same thing
he goes on to show Foster in her own
notes how the world tree of Norse
mythology connects with her own theories
of the universe in the post-credits
scene when Erik meets Nick Fury the
latter unveils the tesseract saying
legend tells us one thing history
another but every now and then we find
something that belongs to both according
to the Red Skull this understanding of
the synergy between magic and science is
precisely what makes him superior to
others as he toys with the tower keeper
who guards the tesseract he tells them
they are alike because what others see
is superstition you and I know to be a
science later when Hitler sends his
underlings to get an update from the Red
Skull one of the Nazis scoffs at the
villain asking him if he plans to win
the war with the magic the Red Skull
corrects him saying science but I
understand your confusion great power
has always baffled primitive man the
merging of science and magic is a
consistent theme even when it's a subtle
suggestion rather than a blatant
statement in Thor the dark world when
Thor brings Jane Foster to Asgard to
find out what's happened to her Foster
is subjected to tests directed by an
Asgardian woman named air Foster thinks
she recognizes what's happening and asks
that's a quantum field generator isn't
it air then tries to tell her it's a
soul Forge like that's something unique
to as dark but Jane then asks does the
soul Forge transfer molecular energy
from one place to another
yes the soul Forge and other Asgardian
tech is operated with the same motion
and touch methods we not only see Tony
Stark using an Iron Man but that we see
in the everyday lives of aliens and
guardians of the galaxy and the
vibranium enhanced Wakanda of black
panther even in Doctor Strange arguably
the magic heart of the MCU the
connections between science and magic
are clear when strange first meets er
the ancient one shows him a chakra chart
an acupuncture chart and an MRI scan she
tells him that each was created by
someone who could see in part but not
the whole she invites him to think of
magic spells as programs describing them
as the source code that shapes reality
when strange asks how he could possibly
ever learn to do what she does the
ancient one responds by asking him how
he was able to be a neurosurgeon in
other words magic and science go hand in
hand in the MCU making it simpler for
audiences to understand and accept it
but then things changed with thor
ragnarok everything changed as the
concept of science equating with magic
got kicked to the wayside for a much
more mythical approach from the
beginning the change is clear searchers
rantings about the coming of Ragnarok or
all about prophecy and prophecy hasn't
reared its head in the MCU before now
without any kind of explanation
suddenly the Asgardians are gods Thor
Loki Odin and hella all refer to
themselves and others as gods I'm the
goddess of death
what were you the god of again in a
second conversation with Odin
complaining that he can't defeat hella
without his hammer oh dan asks Thor are
you so the gut of hammers
hmm Doctor Strange caused Thor the God
of Thunder when he meets him and Thor
refers to himself the same way several
times he even tells Loki you'll always
be the god of mischief the about-face is
stark enough to give any audience member
whiplash and it's not just about the
status of Odin and company either this
untethering from the rule that science
and reason has to inform everything that
happens at the MCU has another obvious
effect in the film Doctor Strange was
released only a year before Thor
Ragnarok yet in the scene where Thor
finds himself in the Greenwich Village
sanctum sanctorum magic already works
much differently than it did in strange
his own film take a seat in Doctor
Strange magic is portrayed as following
specific rules which lends itself to
that notion of science being
intrinsically connected to it almost
everything that different magic users do
begins with the fiery patterns they make
in the air or in mystical items imbued
with power like sling rings or strangest
cloak of levitation but when Thor and
strange meet in Thor Ragnarok things
work differently strange teleports
himself and Thor throughout the house at
a pace that disorients and annoys Thor
without using his sling ring or even
making the slightest motion with his
hand
Thor finds himself in explicably holding
a cup of tea and then a bottomless mug
of beer in strange his own film these
things would seem impossible yet here
magic is being handled in the more
undefinable way we see in older comics
by dropping the pretense that science
must be the base of all supernatural
elements of the film the characters are
free to lean into their talents no
matter how unusual they are open ends
ironically even though thor ragnarok
ends the established godlessness of
Asgard and the magic science synergy
much of what makes the film so fun is
exactly what it's throwing away Thor's
adventures on the planet sakaar give us
some of the best
moments of the film it's worth Thor
battles the Hulk where he meets the
hilarious Grandmaster and the tough as
nails Valkyrie and of course it's where
we learn about Thor and Loki 'he's
well-loved childhood game get help
none of it would make sense without
everything that's come before and
everything Ragnarok is wilfully
forgetting the fact that the Asgardians
were established as aliens instead of
gods is precisely why Thor Loki and
Valkyrie are not as out of their element
as they otherwise might be door isn't
shocked by meeting a group of aliens
moments after he arrives on Sekar he
isn't confused by their technology
Valkyrie clearly has an intuitive
command over her spaceship
Loki navigates the technology so well
he's able to steal security codes from
the Grand Master Odin's sons wield laser
rifles as comfortably as we've seen them
wield hammers and daggers respectively
and when Thor steals the Grand Master's
ship he says it should be no problem to
figure out because after all it's just
another spaceship indeed he handles it
just fine even Bruce Banner with all his
doctorates is utterly shocked by the
fact that he's on an alien planet
stressing him out to the point where he
almost turns back into the other guy
over him yet the comparably meat-headed
Thor is just fine as if he were not a
god but just another alien exactly like
we've been told up until now we're also
left to wonder who else might be a
supposed God in this story in the comics
it isn't just Thor and Loki and the
named characters of Asgard who are gods
everyone on Asgard is a god scourge the
executioner Lady SIF the warriors three
Heimdall and all the rest every man
woman and child if there's an Asgardian
dude who cleans the toilets of Asgard
then the dude who cleans the toilets of
Asgard is a god does this mean all the
Asgardians of the MCU are gods if it
does then why are they such cannon
fodder when it comes to fighting hell as
zombies or Dark Elves
how could there be such a thing in
Asgard as an innocent civilian or
bystander if they're God's they should
all be kicking butt and taking names
meanwhile it might not make sense that
Loki is called again if the character is
actually a frost giant adopted by the
Asgardians
see a God are you a God if you just hang
out with other gods the questions are
endless then there's the matter of how
the changes thor ragnarok made to the
MCU
will impact future movies in spite of
its huge cast Avengers infinity war
should give Thor a key role in the fight
against Thanos Thanos even without the
Infinity stones is supposedly the most
powerful being in the universe if Thor
is now a gun then he's probably going to
be the only one even able to keep up
with a mad Titan if not we may have to
wonder whether the developments in
Ragnarok might harm the integrity of the
MCU
if Marvel Studios decides to ultimately
nix the whole concept of Asgardian gods
in a future feature it could make things
even more confusing and convoluted on
the other hand allowing creators the
freedom to change the rules once in a
while is what makes the comics such a
rush to read so who knows maybe this
abrupt alteration is just part of a
bigger plan to shake things up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and bring in
some real magic science and continuity
be damned thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]